While you were fighting Rennala, did you ever
wonder what words her children were singing?It's
hard to make out with all the chaos going
on around you..but if we extract the voice
files from this fight, then we can hear, and
read this: Sleep tight, bound tight by Mother's
amber."Mother's amber" is Rennala's amber
egg.
Within this egg is the Great Rune of the Unborn
- a shard of the Elden Ring given to her by
Radagon, her former husband.
With it, she rebirths juvenile scholars over
and over again.
According to the Juvenile Scholar Set, "Rebirth
is as sleep to them, and with each awakening,
memory fades into oblivion".
Hence the lullaby.Sleep tight, find life,in
Mother's umbra.Umbra is basically another
word for "shadow".
Specifically though, umbra often refers to
the region of darkest shadow during a lunar
eclipse.
All of a sudden, this line becomes hugely
poetic.
Rennala is the Queen of the Full Moon..and
her children are being reborn in her umbra
- the shadow of her moon.
(NOTE: This symbolism of eclipse rebirth is
also paralleled in Sol)This game is overflowing
with beautiful secrets and deep hidden meanings..and
I think these secrets videos are a great format
to share them with you all.
What's crazy, as always, are the little details
that From Software place into their games.
Did you know, for example..that Rennala's
Queen's Set gauntlets hide a small secret?
When you equip these, you don't just equip
the bracelets..you equip a tiny ring on your
little finger, as well.
Now, I'm probably reading too much into it
- but it's been documented that wearing a
single ring on the little finger can "advertise
the possession of a costlier piece of apparatus
put away in store"..and that's certainly the
case with Rennala, whose boss room has a locked
chest containing Ranni's Dark Moon Ring.
This is a ring of betrothal, "supposed to
be given by Lunar Princess Ranni to her consort".
THIS ring was locked away by Princess Ranni
herself.
The warning engraved upon the ring reads "Whoever
thou mayest be, take not the ring from this
place.
The solitude beyond the night is better mine
alone.".
With this ring, you can become Ranni's consort,
and unlock a new ending.
The ring goes on to say that "Ranni is an
Empyrean, and any consort of hers would by
rights earn the title of lord".
So obviously, betrothal was an important concept
to the Royal Family - and doubly so, for Ranni.
According to the Dark Moon Greatsword, "it
is long-standing tradition for a Queen of
Caria to bestow a Moon Greatsword upon her
spouse".
As such, you receive the Dark Moon Greatsword
when Ranni takes you as her consort at the
end of her questline.
Now..Rennala was once betrothed to Radagon
- so where then, is his Moon Greatsword?
Well..it's been lost in the consecrated snowfields,
wielded by a misbegotten.
It's this, the Golden Order Greatsword.
Doesn't look like a moon greatsword does it?
Well..that's because it used to be one.
"Greatsword made of light, modeled after the
Elden Ring itself.
Forged by King Consort Radagon to proudly
symbolize the tenets of the Golden Order.
Telltale signs betray that this was once the
greatsword bequeathed to him by his first
wife, Rennala."
So it wasn't just forged - it was reforged.
Radagon fought for the Golden Order, but then
married Rennala and was given a Moon Greatsword.
Then, when he left Rennala to return to the
Golden Order, he reforged his Moonlight Greatsword
into the Golden Order Greatsword instead.
At the back of Rennala's room she keeps a
statue of Radagon, despite him leaving her
so long ago.
This is the same statue design that was commissioned
for the Erdtree capital.
The same statue that reveals that Radagon
is in fact..Marika.
If you're not familiar with the concept of
Radagon being Marika, you should go and watch
my previous lore video.
It lays the groundwork for all the lore I'll
be discussing in the videos to come.
But what I want to talk about isn't the statue
exactly - rather, it's the backing of the
statue.
This criss-cross pattern.
This mesh is actually crazy important to Radagon
as a character.
It's like his seal.
His symbol.
His..Elden Rune.
And it is something you notice EVERYWHERE,
once you start looking for it.
For example, Radagon's Scarseal is "An eye
engraved with an Elden Rune"..and his mesh
pattern is sealed on it.
Next, we see this same pattern on the door
that blocks access to the Erdtree.
Of course, Radagon is inside at this point
- and his seal is a part of what prevents
you from entering.
Next we find it on the Mask of Confidence,
in gold thread sown over the mouthpiece in
a crossed fashion.
It reads: "When Radagon married Rennala, he
ordered the Carian magic preceptors to don
these masks.
To make it clear that all of their matters
were to be kept strictly private".
As you probably know, Radagon was indeed keeping
a lot of secrets.
I want to thank Quelaag, whose work on the
lore I respect a lot, for pointing out the
masks to me!
And finally, this pattern is found..on the
main menu, and the Elden Ring itself.
So why does the Elden Ring have Radagon's
seal upon it?
Well..this is probably a new element added
when Radagon became the vessel for the Elden
Ring.
It's now housed within him.
It makes some sense then that his seal..would
be represented upon the symbol of the Elden
Ring, in some way.
But what does Radagon's mesh represent?
It's very orderly, like Radagon himself - so
I do think the character is represented in
the design..and the Scarseal item clarifies
"These seals represent the lifelong duty of
those chosen by the gods".
The stronger version of the Scarseal is the
Soreseal, and it reads "Solemn duty weighs
upon the one beholden; not unlike a gnawing
curse from which there is no deliverance."
The red seals on these eyes become so embedded
that their shape becomes barely recognisable.
A heavy duty, indeed.
Of course, Marika has seal talismans as well.
And as with Radagon, the talismans reveal
the shape of her seal - hers is a crucifix.
You would have seen this crucifix all throughout
the Lands Between.
It's present in every area because the crucifix
is the symbol of the summoning pool, but you'll
find a ton of crucifixes in Limgrave especially,
where there are countless undying, screaming
bodies pinned up.
I'll admit - I'm not sure why these bodies
only scream at night, nor why they've been
punished in this way..not why they're smouldering..nor
why they're undying, even after you release
the rune of death.
You could interpret this as her being in shackles
for shattering the Elden Ring, as the Elden
Beast also likes to punish us with a crucifix
of its own - but beyond these shackles, it's
undeniable that this pose became a symbol
of her entire reign.
For example, go and look at the statues of
Marika throughout the game.
All feature her with her hands flung out,
almost as if she's mimicing the shape of the
rune of death..This woman, this god, removed
death from the land, and I think this posture
is the symbol of that blessing, and her seal.
The vertical line coming down through the
center of the Elden Ring is present in almost
all of the Great Runes symbols, and it really
helps in aligning them all together to form
the shape of the Elden Ring.
Something like this, perhaps?
But how many Great Runes do you really need
to complete the Elden Ring?
Well..there would have been a point in your
playthrough where the Two Fingers tell you
that you only need to collect Two Great Runes
to earn the right to become Elden Lord, and
to restore the Golden Order.
You might have thought this was strange right?
How can the Elden Ring be complete with just
two Great Runes?
Well remember: Morgott guards the Erdtree..he's
not an optional boss at all..and with his
Great Rune..you have three - and the Elden
Ring starts to look pretty complete at that
point.
Complete enough to restore order, apparently.
In fact, even if you get every Great Rune
in the game and theoretically fully restore
the Elden Ring - it's possible that it's still
not really complete.
For example, In Faram Azula, there's an even
bigger Elden Ring..with even more rings.
Nothing explicitly mentions this Mega Elden
Ring, so speculation is all we have.
My best guess at this stage is that maybe
this is some primordial form of the Elden
Ring?
Since it has more rings, maybe this is something
that existed in an earlier age?
As for the roots, I kind of interpret this
as the way the Mega Elden Ring's blessings
might have been filtered down to the world?
In a more natural way, perhaps?
Elden Ring will almost certainly receive DLC
- so I wouldn't be surprised if we were able
to collect more Great Runes in the future.
From a gameplay point of view it makes sense
- there is a system for equipping Great Runes
in the game, after all.
But from a lore point of view - we do know
of at least one other Great Rune that we haven't
found yet.
Ranni's.
Ranni is said to have cast aside her Great
Rune,
There was a really interesting post a little
while ago by reddit user FlintVonEverec who
proposed that Ranni's Great Rune could have
been hidden on the moon itself which..I mean
it just makes so much sense, considering who
she is.
Amazing theory.
Amazing find.
I remember noticing that shape on the moon
so long ago in promotional material for the
game, and it's crazy to think this symbol
might have ended up having a meaning like
this.
Another thing that we speculated about before
the game was officially released..was this
line of dialogue, from Margitt.
Cower in fear of the night.
The hands of the Fell Omen shall brook thee
no quarter.
Now that the game is released, I think we
have an explanation for why he says this.
The hands of the Fell Omen might just be the
Night Cavalry.
According to their set "The Night's cavalry,
who now wander the dim roads of night, were
once led by the Fell Omen".
That said, the set makes it clear that they
USED to be led by the Fell Omen, and that
they're not any more.
So take it with a grain of salt, I guess.
In fact, you should always be taking what
I say with a grain of salt - especially in
these early days, as we're all still figuring
out the lore.
For example, since posting my recent Lore:
Explained video, I've developed my own theories
further, and read and listened to some much
needed criticisms.
So, to prevent a couple of outdated theories
spreading I've actually gone and spliced out
some problematic sections of that video in
the YouTube editor.
If you haven't watched that video, I still
maintain that it's worth watching - but in
case you have watched that video already,
I'm going to take some time now to update
you all on how my ideas have changed.
First off, there's a small part in the previous
video where I call the Erdtree a parasite.
So..first - parasite was just the wrong word
to use.
Calling it parasitic almost characterises
the Erdtree as sinister just for feeding off
an energy source, which is..wrong, obviously.
It's a tree.
That's what trees do.
It's probably wrong to characterise the Erdtree
at all, to be honest.
In the words of Quelaag, another lore creator
- the Erdtree is more symbiotic, if anything.
Symbiotic is a good word, I think.
Because we know the Erdtree was symbiotic
with one thing at least - the Great Tree.
Root Resin tells us that "the Erdtree's roots
were once entwined with that of the Erdtree".
In my video I also put forward that the Great
Tree was where the crucible of life was located..and
that this Great tree and this power source
was likely what the Erdtree drew upon for
power.
Now, I still don't think I'm necessarily wrong
on this, but I should have better shown my
reasoning for this statement in the video.
So, now I'd like to point out, if only briefly,
that my main piece of evidence for the Great
Tree being the location of the crucible of
life, is Crucible Knight Siluria's Tree Helm.
This is a "crucible" helmet..that features
"Great tree ornamentation".
To me, if these knights of the crucible were
fashioning their gear after the Great Tree
specifically..then that's a fairly strong
connection, to me, that the crucible is linked
to the Great Tree.
However, it bears mentioning that no item
descriptions explicitly link the crucible
with the Great Tree..it's all indirect evidence
- so bear that in mind.
Next, I should have elaborated when I said
that Marika killed the Fell God.
She didn't.
Rather, as per the One-Eyed Shield, it's "believed"
that she killed the fell god.
Of course, other descriptions like "flame
of the fell god" make it clear that "the fell
god still lurks within the Fire Giants", and
we'll go more into detail on that later.
She certainly suppressed the power of the
Fell God..you could say she defeated it - but
it's clearly still a force in the world.
and lastly, I've removed the statement that
Malenia and Miquella were born after the shattering.
This was said under the assumption that they
must have been born from a single conjoined
god after the shattering, but of course, you
can also choose to believe that they were
born of Radagon and Marika before they were
conjoined post-shattering, and I actually
think that's the more likely option at this
point, so yeah - these twins were very likely
born before the shattering.
I also no longer believe the divine towers
were built after the shattering, and I've
removed that point from the video as well.
So thank you, to those who critiqued me politely.
I'm always happy to admit that I'm wrong.
It means I'm learning.
So I'm going to make more of an effort to
have my scripts peer reviewed, in the future.
So I'm not All Knowing.
Not yet, anyway.